well it was interesting too because it
it was the there were reports that it
was an Algerian immigrant and then
immediately yeah the BBC and all of
these other outlets were like it wasn't
an Algerian immigrant he was an
immigrant 20 years ago so he's not an
imigrant that's different and it turns
out he's never had a job you know he's
been living on the do the whole time yes
and when you look at that it's
absolutely insane and those those hate
speech laws um one of the one of the
parts of that law it's says a hate crime
is any criminal offense any criminal
offense which is perceived by the victim
or any other person to have been
motivated by Prejudice based on a
person's age disability race color
nationality ethnicity religion sexual
orientation or gender so it's any
criminal offense perceived as being
motivated which means the government
decides regardless it's messed up but do
you think this guy who perpetrated
attack would be charged with a hate
crime no of course not